sea turtles are ancient mariners
present in all but earth's coldest
oceans these marine reptiles are well
adapted
to a life on the moon
sea turtles have existed since the time
of the dinosaurs
the earliest known marine turtle lived
about 120 million years ago named
desmetochaelus padillai it was six feet
long and had the characteristic features
of modern sea turtles including a
carapace or top shell and paddle-like
limbs
today there are seven species of sea
turtles with the largest being the
leatherback growing as long as eight
feet and weighing up to two thousand
pounds it is larger than known fossils
of its prehistoric ancestor bee padilla
sea turtles can lay more than 150 eggs
at a time
called the clutch these large egg
deposits help ensure the survival of sea
turtle hatchlings
once a female lays her eggs she returns
to the sea leaving her hatchlings to
fend for themselves
fewer than 0.1
of hatchlings survive to adulthood in
part due to numerous predators on the
beach
emerging in large numbers increases the
chance that some will survive
a sea turtle sex is determined by
temperature
unlike most vertebrates a sea turtle sex
is not determined by sex chromosomes
instead the temperature of the nest
determines the sex of the hatchlings
when temperatures are warm at about 88
degrees fahrenheit most of the
hatchlings will be female but when
temperatures are cooler less than around
82 degrees fahrenheit most of the
hatchlings will be male
[Music]
sea turtles use earth's magnetic fields
to navigate
sea turtles have geomagnetic abilities
which serve as an internal
gps the turtles have particles of
magnetite a magnetic mineral in their
brains the magnetite likely plays a role
in orienting sea turtles to earth's
magnetic poles similar to a compass
baby sea turtles imprint on the unique
magnetic signature of the beaches where
they hatch
this magnetic map can guide them back to
the same beaches several years later to
lay their own eggs
all seven sea turtle species are
threatened with extinction
once abundant sea turtle populations
have dramatically declined in the past
two centuries
fishing is a major threat to sea turtles
as they become caught in fishing nets as
bycatch or accidental catch illegal
harvesting of turtle eggs trafficking
and turtle products and ocean pollution
are also concerns
however
policies have been enacted to reduce
bycatch protect turtle habitats and
prohibit the killing of sea turtles and
their eggs
by continuing this kind of intervention
humans can help stop the decline of sea
turtles helping keep these ancient
mariners in the world's oceans
[Music]
you